Listen, I've got a test for you.
I'm going to set up a fake scene
and see if you can tell
—that I am...
—In front of a green screen.
Yeah. He is.
But here's my question.
When is AI going to replace this
clunky 20th century invention?
I mean, after all, AI is
the technology
that can draw masterpieces
and generate poems...
and hunt down our loved ones
and kill them...
so it can totally
beat out a color.
Right?
Right???
Okay.
I found a fantastic picture
of a happy family.
I am going to get rid of their background
to show you some of the ways
that we have taught AI
how to do it.
I can start by just separating
the foreground
from the background.
A lot of fast AI programs
do it this way
or it can do segmentation...
where I figure out and label
each part of the picture and
remove what I want.
If I get even more
fine grained
I can label each instance
in a segment...
like Sheila, Lorraine,
and Sheila Junior...
and then get rid of the wall
and the floor.
And Sheila Junior.
She knows what she did.
AI has gotten really good at
splitting stuff up,
at segmentation.
For example, Meta AI
just released a new segmentation model
that can do this...
really easily!
An AI will use different methods
depending on the job
that it's told to do.
But it's a bit different
when you're trying to make
a really good matte...
a perfect cut out.
So you can add whatever
background you want.
This is really hard stuff.
See the hair?
That's often the key obstacle.
Today, a lot of AIs basically
train off people doing what
I am doing now...
some labeling people
but also extremely tedious
separations
of the foreground from
the background.
For one dataset, people at Adobe
took pictures like this
went through just like me
and made a perfect matte
You can see they left out
some really fine hair here.
AII then looks at these matte and
learns how to create one.
They might get more practice
by putting their matte over
different backgrounds and having it try
to cut out the person
again and again.
I just want to be clear here
the way AI learned
how to do this
because some people were squinting
at their computer...
erasing backgrounds and
it learned to copy that.
Others have expanded
the stuff AI can learn from
by taking greenscreen footage.
They manually keyed out the footage
removed the green...
and then the model practiced
with those mattes on
different backgrounds...
trying to cut them out
over and over again
until it got really good.
That helps the robot
improve its skills.
Researcher Roni Sengupta and
his coauthors made this dataset.
They used that data to make a really,
really, really good green screen.
And then another one with
some researchers from Bytedance
the owners of TikTok.
I am going to
pull it up now.
It is like a Zoom background
on steroids.
I especially had to instruct
all my subjects
to play with the hair because
there is no other part
where this transparency
becomes more visible
than the hair and the glasses.
So I'm looking at people's faces
like this when they turn...
The glasses comes into effect.
There is transparency.
So in practice you are trying
to predict something
which is mostly zero in most part
of the background...
and it's mostly one at
the center of my body
but around my age and the hair
and everything...
It has some values that is
between zero and one.
Between zero and one.
He's talking about where the AI
has trouble predicting
what is Roni and
what is office.
And that's a hard problem
to solve.
So AI green screens
are great, right?
You don't need a big
green screen.
But they fail in other ways.
This is TikTok.
Let me put on the green screen effect.
So it looks good.
But do you see how it's
kind of clamping down
on my head right here?
That's because these AI green screens
are optimized for speed
not necessarily for Hollywood-level quality.
It doesn't look bad at first
but then when you see
the comparison, you realize
exactly how much information
it's cutting out.
In that fancy loft
I stood close to a really
textured background.
Do you see how the
AI green screen
had trouble making
a perfect separation?
It got some of the numbers right
but it's confused about others.
And the final problem is something
that traditional green screens can do
that AI green screens
have to adapt to.
I'll put my laptop's here,
way in front of me.
The green screen has no problem
getting rid of all the green
because it doesn't have any knowledge
of what's in the frame.
But the TikTok green screen is not
a real green screen.
It's trained to look for people.
So it's going to cut out my computer...
even though I might want it
in the shot.
That's a problem that traditional
green screens...
obviously don't have.
Somebody has to tell the AI
what to do.
A lot of advanced
AI video editors
do this by making masks instead.
A mask is basically
an outline.
So the computer has you
click the outline
and does its best to make a mask
and move it along t
hroughout the frame.
It can be a car,
a person
an animal out,
an object.
And so we train a model just to
be able to recognize that
in a very accurate way.
right?
You want a perfect copy?
Perfect match.
Okay. So this is
Chris Valenzuela.
He is the CEO of this very popular
AI-focused editor called Runway.
Their green screen tool is
one way of solving this
AI green screen problem
by having you choose what
you want to keep...
rather than just removing
the background.
Where I see artificial intelligence
being very helpful
for video and creative endeavors is that...
It's not an automation tool.
It's not something that will just
replace end-to-end
the whole process.
It will just help you reduce
and replace the boring aspects
of a process.
We are seeing two kinds of AI
emerge currently
for any kind of filmmaking
visual effects things.
One that is very
purpose driven where...
we want to give cinematographers
actual control over
what is going to happen.
And another one
which we want random people
to post their videos
and create cool effects.
We imagine green screens
and AI as switches.
They make more sense on a graph
of speed and quality.
TikTok’s might be here.
An editing program might go here.
And a greenscreen could go here.
Good preparation can improve quality...
but perfection in almost every case...
still requires an artist
to finish the job.
Is the model 100% there yet?
Probably not, but it's 90%.
And then 90% is significant enough...
to reduce the time of translating hours
into minutes.
That means less time
squinting at screens...
and more time in the loft
you rented to make this video
or with your family.
Must destroy Sheila Junior.
Okay.
Okay. One more thing.
We get a slightly cooler
background than this?
Okay, that's slightly.
So a couple of years ago.
I mean, this video that's called
“The technology that's replacing
the green screen”
And that's true.
It’s these giant screens that are often
hooked up to a game engine...
and they provide realistic lighting
and movement of the background.
It's amazing stuff.
But since that video
and as the technology has become
more widespread...
visual effects artists have been open
that often they end up
roto-ing even these images.
What is roto-ing?
Basically, it means that they
replace the background.
They meticulously trace out
the characters...
and replace the background once again.
Even though they were supposed to
have it in-camera.
Now, this doesn't always happen
and there are still huge benefits
to having accurate lighting on set.
But the point is simple.
If you put those amazing LED walls
on our little graph...
they would still be just short...
of the perfection that you can get
from an artist...
who has a lot of time
on their hands.